hi I'm Anna got even i'm currently at
Carnegie Mellon University at the
Australian campus I'm graduating in
december two thousand nine with a
Masters of Science in public policy and
management
our Adelaide's a great place to live and
I was actually born here so I've got
kind of family and ties here I did think
about going to pittsburgh but the ease
of living here is second to none it's
six minutes door to door the weather's
generally nice
it gives me I'm obviously bit older I've
got a law and a science background and
it gives me parts of the puzzle that
really fill out my education to make me
in some ways of a renaissance thinker to
be able to deal with the complex
problems that are facing and
corporations public sector and the world
new general
the faculty is great the standard of
professors is quite profound they're in
lots ways are quite different from one
another and which really adds a nice bit
of juxtapositioning and so that you've
got somebody who is just absolutely
brilliant in policy and then you've got
someone who's like a real numbers person
that kind of demystify as a whole sort
of a lot of area where you know you've
spent sort of other times in your life
going I really I shown you how to do the
finance sort of better I'm kind of sort
of dog paddling to kind of catch up and
stuff so you kind of your really
interact with and the different
professors in quite different ways and
it's wonderful for more information
about the characters of the university
or anything about the course please go
visit w WM z mu edu a you